okay and we're live for our take a half
day edition of comics and
coffee maybe we should call it like
coffee or comics and a drink of water or
something like that because we end up
doing this in the afternoon instead of
the morning I think we've done it like
twice in the morning and twice in the
afternoon but a lot of you folks
overseas across the pond from the United
States we're like hey Rob like you got
to do this later man because like it's
early my time where it's really my time
or something like that and some of you
guys were like I'm on the west coast and
I don't want to have to be up at like
8:00 in the morning but it's whatever
it's all good either way we'll we'll get
it sorted out properly
so um first things first man I am
feeling good I am having a great morning
it is it's nice it's well not a really
great morning I woke up like half an
hour ago
so it's like 12 o'clock in the afternoon
I hit up S and s's like I just woke up
and I was like well I mean in that case
I guess uh I'm still getting out of bed
I got to get lunch s's just now getting
out of bed at 12:30 and um it's uh it's
funny to me I'm actually talking to him
on Skype let's send him a message let's
call him
lazy
lazy I got to put LOL so he knows I'm
messing around but um anyway a wild Rob
appeared yes a wild Rob has appeared see
somebody's like it's 328 here in
Australia 328 in the morning my God man
you guys are up late like it amazes me
how late you guys stay up to watch my
stuff it's weird but um so lexity
ComiCon is this weekend I went yesterday
and I was going to go to go again today
but I was like you know what because
originally I was going to put off comics
and coffee and I was like you know what
we're going to go ahead and just go to
Lexi Comic Con today but after being
there yesterday I was like you know what
I'm not going to blow off the guys from
from my channel I'm not going to not
hang out with you guys so I was like
okay like we're going to go ahead just
do comics and coffee and uh we're just
not going to worry about Lexing and
Comic Con cuz in all honesty it wouldn't
all that great
but Lexington's a small town and usually
small town comic book conventions unless
you're talking about huge ones like
Denver Maybe not maybe Denver I don't
know i' never been tover but Denver is a
big town unless you're talking about one
like New York Comic Con or San Diego
which New York is the only other one
I've been to um I don't think they're
going to be all that great they're going
to be decent enough but
um yeah let's see s messaged me
back uh I would but oh
wow
[Music]
um all right I sound like Benny
like Vinnie's like whenever you type it
on the keyboard it's
hilarious I do like cheese actually I'm
a big fan of cheese um I try not to put
cheese on everything but I'm probably
going to go get a salad from Kroger here
in a little bit and I'll probably put
some cheese on that because cheese I
think I think cheese is one of those
things like salt or pepper although you
really can't have too much salt you got
to tone down the salt a little bit so
you don't dehydrate yourself but I think
that cheese is one of those things where
it goes good with everything you can
literally put cheese on anything and
it'll probably taste better because of
it one of the really one of the coolest
things that I was ever introduced to was
a friend of mine named Ross and uh
whenever the McRib came out we would
just be like oh yes McRib time and we
would go and we would like Hammer some
MC RBS and so Ross is like all right
dude here's what you got to do you got
to get some cold cheese you can't have
like regular you know non-refrigerated
cheese you got to have cold cheese you
got to have a big thick slice of cheddar
cheese Sharp cheddar cheese I think he
always said it was and you got to put
that on your sandwich and for the
longest time I was like all right
whatever it's whatever you know it
doesn't really matter that much to me
and so he had some cheese and he was
like here dude just put this on there
and tell me what you think and I was
like okay I threw it on there and I was
like this is probably the greatest
invention in the history of mankind like
cold sharp cheddar cheese on a mcreb
sandwich is
amazing oh my God you don't like cheese
pizza cheese or pizza oh my God so
what's molecule man up to that is a very
interesting question that is a very
interesting question what's molecule man
been doing because the last bit of
significance that molecule man had was
in 1985 with Secret Wars issue number
two right guess Secret Wars part two and
he fought the beyonder and people were
like oh god wow this is amazing and he
really hasn't been relevant since fast
forward to
2015 and molecule man is very
relevant molecule man is extremely
relevant but um
yeah
um I'm
live it's uh okay so we're you know what
I'm debating on whether or not I wanted
to like tell you guys what's going on
right now in New Avengers or whether I
want to wait for a video I think we
might wait for a video originally I
wanted to go ahead and just like throw
things in there I wanted to go ahead and
and do a video now about um about the
new Avengers but we're gonna wait until
we get a little bit more information
because right now it's just been like oh
my God this reveal is huge and we don't
really know anything behind it which I
actually didn't think about that it
wasn't until I posted to Twitter and
somebody was like I mean we don't really
know a whole lot and I was like that's a
good point
so yeah we're we all but um it's uh it's
funny to me so anyway um do I see
Daredevil I mean I wasn't where Dar
devil was out yet I mean it might be but
I was where there
was um I thought Daredevil didn't come
out in for a little while hold on a
second let me check and make sure but
thought Daredevil didn't come out until
later on this
year yeah yeah doesn't come out until
later on this year so it's not out yet
cool
um all right let's so first questions do
you think uh Marvel DC killing
characters is a bad idea instead they
could make them retire and act as a
mentor or something
they could um they tried that with Miles
Morales they they actually had that for
a time um when Peter Parker in the
Ultimate Universe died which was a huge
deal and they kept him dead they haven't
brought they never you know never at
least to my knowledge they haven't
brought him back um they had Peter
Parker from the earth 616 continuity
visit Miles Morales and basically say
hey man you're doing you're doing the
Lord's work here and uh it's out
already okay it comes out in April
that's what I thought I was like there's
no way it's it comes it's out already
um but um questions are coming in
already we'll answer that one about Age
of Ultron versus Zombies because that
that was going to be kind of cool but
anyway
um what was I talking about I don't
remember what I was talking about oh
yeah yeah so Peter Parker visits Miles
Morales in the Ultimate Universe and
says hey you're doing the Lord's work
here like keep on keep it on and he's
like awesome but they've never really
like had Peter Parker under under like
play the role of a mentor to a degree
Hank Pim did for Scott Lange but he was
more or less the same thing like like
hey like I think you did a good job here
like this is this is cool and they just
kind of kept on you know keep on keeping
on
but but yeah like he was one of those
cool things um I don't think that'd be a
terrible idea but I think that
ultimately a lot of fans would say if
Peter Parker is going to still be alive
in the Ultimate Universe or in the in
their 616 continuity then they need to
keep him as Spider-Man as opposed to
making somebody else so not really sure
but um all right so to the question uh
what storyline are you looking forward
to in secret Wars I'm personally looking
forward to Age of Ultron versus Marvel
Zombies cuz you know who wouldn't be
that's yeah who wouldn't be I think
that's going to be cool what Marvel has
said is that Age of Ultron and Marvel
zombies are going to be their own
separate universes so Marvel Zombies is
going to be its own separate universe
and we know that Age of Ultron is going
to be its own separate Universe on
Battle World
um what they're going to do and we're
going to we're going to talk about some
cool stuff in The Walking Dead what
they're going to do is they're going to
basically like have the universes fight
each other I think that'll be kind of
kind of cool I'm I don't really see the
point there I mean ultron's a robot so I
don't really see how he could could like
succumb to the effects of being a zombie
but um the thing I'm looking forward to
the most is the Thor core and we're
actually going to start our lead up
today or maybe experiment with it I'm
not really sure but you guys really seem
to enjoy the uh what if Thor was a
Herald of galatis video so we're going
to do a video on what if Jane Foster was
Thor that's actually a what if story
from volume one so I think you guys are
really going to enjoy that one but um
anyway so The Walking Dead all right so
you guys have been like beating me to
death about doing videos about something
other than Marvel and DC Comics and so
we're going to experiment with The
Walking Dead But what we're going to do
with The Walking Dead is we're going to
do like the current events of the TV
show in the comics and so we're going to
talk about the community in the comic
books because I figure why talk about
stuff that happened like four years ago
like that doesn't really seem too
relevant so um we're going to experiment
with that and and it's just going to be
a test thing if it doesn't get a whole
lot of views if a lot of people don't
watch it then I'm probably just not
going to do it again but at the very Le
at least I think it'd be fun to just
kind of dip a toe and something outside
of um of Marvel and DC Comics and sort
of go with there uh go with that so um
hey Rob what do you think of the of
battle work with
spiderverse I don't understand what you
mean like what I think of the battles or
I don't I don't understand what you mean
um talk about Thor versus Wonder Woman
did you like Doom War storyline they did
a few years ago with black panther I
didn't read it I've never been the
biggest fan of Dr Doom to be honest I
think he's a cool villain but I think
he's decent enough um Rick rhymes for
the wind yes um okay so you know what
let's let's just talk about The Walking
Dead for a second so those of you guys
who are not current with the uh with the
com or with those of you guys who want
to have this spoil because let's be
honest guys when you come on to this to
comics and coffee you're going to get
stuff spoiled for you it's just the way
it is things are just going to be
spoiled so let's talk about the
community in The Walking Dead let me
know if you guys want to see that like
like like if you guys want to see that
just type just say yes say yes if you
guys want me to talk about what happens
to the community in the comic
books uh let's
see oh battle World okay
um the battle World War Zone uh all
right let's scroll up and look at this
question again
because it kind of thre me off a little
bit um down scroll down scroll down
scroll down scroll
down all right I lost the
question oh okay what do I think of
Battle world with spiderverse
um I don't know um I'm a little on the
fence about it I am a little on the
fence about wow people are like
no well there's a lot of Nos and a lot
of yeses
um I
think I didn't like spiderverse I really
did not enjoy spider verse I thought
spiderverse was sort of me I thought
spiderverse was sort of could have been
better I think s's idea for what
spiderverse should have been was a much
better story than what we got but the
spiderverse story that we got was just a
byproduct of incursion see here's the
thing guys like they told us I mean this
is what you know what what the Marvel
brass told us during their live stream
um this is what bror told us that
they're basically taking all their
stories and they're focusing on
incursions
spiderverse was really nothing more than
a way to give us an event with
Spider-Man to show us all different
kinds of Spider-Man and Spider women and
then to basically just like thin the
herd that was it that was really the
only basis behind it and I saw that and
I didn't like it I was like this is I
mean a lot of those characters I didn't
care about I was like you know what it
doesn't really matter to me so I don't
know
um anyway it was it was uh it was weird
it was something I didn't I didn't care
too much for right now um which one do
you like more right now convergence or
battle World well in honestly in honesty
um Marvel has a leadup to Secret Wars
all their stories are revolving around
Secret Wars as best as I've been able to
tell with DC it's a little more
difficult to say all their stories are
leading up to this it's it's not as
though they're all leading up to the end
of the universe because the universe
isn't necessarily ending um or I guess
they're not really I guess it's really
hard it's DC is more difficult about
their lead to convergence than Marvel is
about Secret Wars I'll give Marvel that
um Marvel's definitely doing a much
better leadup to
it but in
truth it's really too early to tell it's
really too early to say which one's
better um because one they haven't
really started yet and two they're both
pretty much doing the same thing DC is
consolidating their alternate realities
uh their El worlds and all that kind of
good stuff by having them all sort of
converge into one location and fight
each other Marvel's doing the same thing
Marvel they're doing it by two different
ways DC is using Brainiac to do it and
Marvel's using the uh using romal to do
it so um yes I saw the Daredevil trailer
and the Daredevil trailer looked awesome
okay um let's
see so there were some yeses and there
were some NOS um it's too difficult for
me to tell which one was which one was
on there so yeah we'll um I guess we'll
go ahead and pass on that for right now
and uh we'll do that later
um hey Rob why did Deadpool side with
the pro regist act in Civil War it was
actually really funny it was in cable
and Deadpool issue number 30 I think and
the way it picks up the whole reason is
because he just thinks he would be good
at hunting people like he just wants to
wants to like sh like kill people and
like he tells the president that like he
goes after um West Coast Avengers and
the entire time he thinks he has an
inner monologue when reality he's
actually just talking out loud it's
really funny we covered this during
Civil War but I don't remember which one
it was which is fun I think it's
actually called Deadpool um during in
our our our civil war playlist but um
he actually goes to the president and
the president's like like you're not
supposed to kill people you're just
supposed to capture them and he was like
oh okay but the president's like I'll
give you a badge if you capture cable
because that's all he wants is a badge
like he just wants a badge and to be an
official member of the pro registration
side it's kind of silly but um will I
ever talk about amalgam uh probably I
don't see why not um I thought about
doing the video of what if Superman was
a Herald of galatis which I'm not really
sure if that's something that I'm going
to get into or not but it was actually
kind of cool because he goes and meets
the Fantastic 4 and that kind of good
stuff but um Harley Quinn or Deadpool um
I mean Harley Quinn I think I think
she's got more personality than Deadpool
does Deadpool's just slapstick humor I'm
not really a huge fan of that
um let's see do you think wolverin
should stay dead I honestly think it's
time to put him down um here's the
problem with Wolverine a lot of people
say that because of the way Wolverine
was written and that's the problem it's
all about how Wolverine was written uh
written it's he's not written very well
um I think that initially the stories
were kind of cool especially in the '90s
when he was getting some character
development but he really hasn't gotten
a lot of character development the
problem is Marvel turned Wolverine into
a broadsword whenever there's some major
event wolver reain comes in and just
starts swathing away the criminals just
starts slashing away at everybody using
his claws and he's mindless and he
doesn't think and he's got these stupid
motivations and things like that that's
the problem that Marvel had they
basically made their character
irrelevant and so when the movies came
out and fox said we're not giving you
the rights to the X-Men back Marvel said
okay fine we'll kill off Wolverine but
fans had seen that coming for a long
time fans were saying it's time for him
to go even Wolverine fans were like it's
time for him to go um so I think it
makes sense that they decided to go
ahead and get rid of him um they're
going to bring him back wolver was just
too popular of a character too many
people knew who he was even if they
wanted to see him leave he's too popular
of a character to keep gone forever and
if I guess when when the new installment
of I guess of Wolverine comes out like
the Wolverine series wolver rain 2 I
think it is when that comes out um
they're basically going to bring it back
they're going to bring him back because
it's going to boost sales for Marvel and
at the end of the day regardless of all
the fan service and all that kind of
good stuff Marvel's a company and Marvel
exists to make money and there's no way
they're going to pass up a boost in
sales for Wolverine Comics by not
bringing Wolverine back when the
Wolverine movie comes out or any movie
that features Wolverine comes out so um
I've never really gotten into Saga um I
had uh I talked to V about it and Benny
was like saga's pretty good um I Know
Tiffany I think she says she's a huge
fan of saga I think that Tiffany is
probably going to be my go-to source for
independent Comics which I start
branching out into there Benny was
pretty much saying the same thing like
we had this big meeting and and among
the things we talked about bny started
talking to Tiffany about about Indie
Comics he was kind of picking her brain
and that was a good idea because Tiffany
is really knowledgeable about Indie
comics and so I think that going that
route would be a good way to go but um
let's
see
um
Rick ryes from The Walking Dead versus
Lois
Lane um I know that I'll probably end up
skipping over some of your questions
guys so uh if you really really want
your question answered just keep asking
it and U and I'll I'll I'll try to get
it answered if I can
um will wolver rain join the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in terms of joining
The Avengers absolutely not there's no
way Fox is going to give up the rights
or in any facet let Marvel have any part
of that cash cow Wolverine draws people
to Fox films if Wolverine went to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe even if they
were sharing the rights even if
Wolverine was appearing in Fox and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe people would
start to deviate away from Fox because
Marvel would do it better they would
make his character much better with
every oh God it'd be it'd be nuts
there's no way Fox absolutely not Fox
would never let that happen it's it's a
cash cow for them
um do you think Miss Marvel kamicon is
going to continue post battle World
honestly I haven't really read kamicon
um I'm not a big fan of her I don't know
how many people feel the same way I do I
don't know how many people don't really
enjoy her at all but I would go as far
as to say she's probably not as popular
as Carol Danver among older comic book
fans in terms of newer comic book fans I
know she struck a chord with a lot of
people who have Middle Eastern descent
they really wanted to see some
representation in comic books and I
think they got it with kamicon but I
think that uh for the for the overall
mainstream comic book fan base I don't
think she's that popular of a character
but again I haven't really read um you
know much by Kam Khan she just never
really interested me because she wasn't
a character I could identify with um you
know for me I was always a big fan of
Carol Danvers because of her search for
uh I guess for finding a place to belong
but also what she represented with
regards to feminism
so uh well I mean I don't want you to
spam I want you guys I mean don't like
spam your question over and over and
over again you know just ask it every if
I don't answer it just ask it every once
in a
while
predictions of sky on Agents of
Shield I think that she will be trained
adequately in Shield I think she'll
undergo the same kind of training
regiment she went through in the comics
with regards to Shield she's going to
learn how to use her power she's going
to learn Precision the real question
here is what do we think they're going
to do with Raina because Raina I think
is going to be our introduction to the
inhuman royal family I think it's
somewhere along the line in Agents of
Shield Vin Diesel if he's going to be
playing blackbolt is going to have a
cameo Marvel's got the money to do or I
guess the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Disney do they have the money to do it
they'll they'll be like hey dude look
we'll pay you like a million dollars if
you just show up for an episode of
Agents of Shield like or even he just
has to like be in there or just
reference him just say you know like
have at the end of an episode just have
Raina there and just say have like the
the the reader the guy that grabbed her
and uh took her I guess uh teleported
away with her just have him appear at
aant and just say I've brought her to
see blackbolt in the inhuman royal
family she's a new inhuman and has to
learn how to use her powers and then
just cut the episode at that like that
would be huge um which titles of Secret
Wars has you most
excited um Thor cor is really the one
that has me the most excited I mean I
will admit like Marvel zombies and in
age of Voltron I think would be kind of
cool um but a lot of the stories are
going to be doing they're going to be
rewriting I think so pretty much all the
classics have me interested um future
imperfect is I don't know kind of me uh
Planet Hulk will be interesting uh years
of Future Past I'm really looking
forward to I really want to see what
they do with that if they basically
culminate Days of Future Past and um
Days of Future present or if they just
leave all that out and just rewrite Days
of Future Past entirely um Infinity
Gauntlet has me interested I'm really
cool I'm I'm really interested to see
what what they do um thoughts on the new
DC films on the 10 new DC what 10 new DC
films are they coming out with I wasn't
aware they were coming out I assume
they're animated films because DC has it
when it comes to the animated thing
they're they're about as good as Marvel
is um let's look that up
10 new DC movies oh 11 new DC movies in
development uh let's
see Justice leag dark Wonder Woman
Aquaman oh you're talking about
liveaction films I thought you were just
talking about um Regular film or
animated films um maybe it's a
combination of both I'm not sure
um let's
see I think that
uh I think Shazam would be cool but we
saw the animated film with him and Black
Adam so that was kind of like man it was
whatever but I don't know um I need to
do some more reading about those
characters before I decide whether or
not I'd enjoy them uh let's
see do I think a planet Hulk movie will
come out um well they had I mean as you
you know like I said they had the
cartoon movie they're not going to do a
planet Hulk movie by itself I think uh
Marvel's come out I think Kevin fige or
fagy or whoever how you pronounced his
last name had come out and said that
they're not going to do a um a
standalone Planet Hulk film because one
it would just be insanely expensive and
two because they just don't want to do
anything more with the Incredible Hulk
um what do you think of the Grayson
comic I'm not a big fan of the Grayson
comic um I thought the Grayson comic was
was going to be interesting me and bny
actually had a really cool conversation
about this um Tim Grayson or dick
Grayson's Nightwing was really cool I
really like that idea him going on with
Grayson and becoming this kind of you
know contract guy I dig that too much I
liked it when he was in blood Haven
which I guess is destroyed now but I
liked it when he was in blood Haven and
he was basically that version of Batman
like I thought that was a great way for
DC to keep his character but obviously
you can't keep a character the same way
forever otherwise you run into the same
kind of problem Marvel does so um yes
there would be a Punisher explained
video at some point in time and Marvel
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has the
rights to Punisher those rights were
handed back over after Punisher war zone
which was a total
catastrophe um well moonight can
continue I'm actually not sure see
here's the thing guys we don't know
what's going to be going forward after
Secret Wars we know that some of those
realities are going to be killed off
some of those realities are going to go
away but we don't know what's going to
take their place we don't know how the
the Earth 616 continuity is going to
continue we don't know what all is going
to take place we don't know what
characters are still going to be alive
after Secret Wars is over Secret Wars is
going to be this great big Melting Pot
of conflict and what comes after that is
going to be the Marvel Universe going
forward so we'll actually have to wait
until Secret Wars is over to see what
can continues after that which is going
to be really good for you guys who want
to get into comic books for those of you
guys who are new to comics and who are
like oh my God there's just so much
continuity and I don't know where to
start just give it time just watch my
videos and give it time once once Secret
Wars is over then that's when you'll
basically be in a good spot to start and
anything where you're not sure about I
mean we'll be able to explain it if they
if they keep the backstory of Spider-Man
the same if they say Spider-Man's
continuity has been the same all this
time then we'll just do a quick rundown
on the continuity of Spider-Man and then
we can just go forward with him in
secret Wars
so um who do I think the villain in
Doctor Strange will be it'll probably be
MTO I don't know why it wouldn't be um
dorm was just too big of a villain for a
first Doctor Strange
film uh let's
see who's my favorite superhero
character uh the centy Robert
Reynolds uh let's
see do I like Spider-Man not
really his superpower is complaining so
um
let's see would
you oh who would I put in a moonnight
live action film uh Tom Hardy Tom Hardy
would be a great Mark Spectre but he's
pretty much good in
everything uh let's
see uh what do you think about the
upcoming I zombie TV show I actually
haven't heard of it so I don't know but
I love anything that has to do with
zombies so I'll definitely check it out
uh what do I think will happen in the
Captain America Civil War movie um h
we've talked about this so much oh my
god um to make this short because I'm
not going to go into a half hour long
diet tribe like I did before um I think
it's going to be a leadup to what takes
place after infinity War so um let's see
new costumes after Poston convergence
for DC thoughts please um I think some
characters are due for a costume change
a lot of them got costume changes with
new 52 but people a lot of people hated
the new costumes which I don't think it
really matters their costumes I don't
saying why costumes matter that much if
you okay explain that to me like those
of you guys who were stickers for
costumes explain why the costumes matter
like why does it matter what Superman's
costume looks
like Jimmy Johns versus Subway God
Subway sounds good I've had Jimmy Johns
for the last few days or so Subway is
better because Subway has hot sandwiches
Jimmy John's only has cold sandwiches
however however and this is a big
however Jimmy Johns has the Italian
nightclub
and I don't really know if that can be
beaten so
um you always say you don't like
Spider-Man but you're excited about him
being in the MCU shouldn't you be
unhappy um well all right Spider-Man in
the comics to me is annoying I think
that Spider-Man in the films would be a
lot more interesting um see to me
Spider-Man in the comics has no real
relevance he's completely unimportant he
serves no real purpose I don't
understand he's Spider-Man I think is
still here I know people are probably
going to if I know people are going to
hate me I know some of you guys are
going to lambas me in the chat for this
some of you guys are going to be like
Boo his Rob boo his um to me
Spider-Man's not relevant anymore
Spider-Man was important when he first
came out because he set the status quo
for teenagers now I mean you You' got
characters that can warp reality you've
got guys who have a level of
intelligence that is far beyond where
Peter Parker's even at Peter Parker
admits that they're a character like
black panther for example is Way Beyond
Peter Parker I mean you've got
characters who can that have a level of
strength that exceeds Peter Parker by
Leaps and Bounds who by all stretch of
the imagination could easily thw Peter
Parker and then you've got Spider-Man
you got this character among all that
stuff I mean you you know you got Emma
Frost one of the most powerful telepaths
in the history of the world you had
genan gray who was almost a cosmic
entity with the amount of power that she
possessed she was on par with characters
like galatis with the amount of power
she possessed and when she was the white
crown of the Phoenix or when she was uh
the yeah the white crown of the Phoenix
I think she had powers that suers Ceda
galactic she was nearly omnipotent with
her abilities you have Franklin Richards
you had mad Jim Jaspers you got Mr M
from mutant Town who has reality warping
Powers you've got Dr Doom you've got
apocalypse you've got you had Onslaught
at one point in time you've got Magneto
you've got all these characters and then
you've got a dude who can climb up walls
and shoot webbing out of his hands with
little mechanisms that he developed and
he's got a spider
sense I I think that speaks for
itself Spider-Man I guess maybe he's
funny from time to time but Spider-Man
just isn't important like he's just
completely
irrelevant um I seem to fav overpowered
characters not necessarily I just
recognize that in the realm of of
Godlike characters there comes a point
where you have to say let's th out the
ones who don't matter and Spider-Man is
one of those guys um let's
see was it a mass mad Celestial shown
wielding the infinity stone at the
collectors and the Guardians of the
Galaxy movie we don't know that and and
here is a kicker see a lot of you guys
who watched our video about Franklin
Richards you knew about um about future
foundation like we talked about future
foundation we talked about the Matt
celestials and we talked about all these
characters who were these crazy powerful
you know things that were going on and
so on and so forth but um we had talked
about how in an alternate universe the
Mad celestials the celestials of that
alternate reality had forced the uh that
universe's dissident or I guess
inhabitants to worship them as Gods um
they wielded the power of the infinity
gems they wield you know so on and so
forth made themselves super powerful um
I don't think that's a mad Celestial I
think that's just the Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of a Celestial it could
be different it could be that that
version of the celestial was wielding
the infinity gem it could be that much
like the Earth 616 version of the
celestials they judge planets to to
decide whether or not they should
continue existing because they created
life there and they're deciding whether
or not that life should continue whether
their experiments worked and it could be
that was an experiment that failed we
don't really know what the intention was
um The Collector doesn't really go on to
say they were drunk with power or
anything like that he just says they
wielded incredible power
so what time is it here it's uh 1
o'clock in the
afternoon uh John Stewart or Hal Jordan
for the Green Lantern movie I liked John
Stewart I thought he was a solid Green
Lantern which we need to do the Green
Lanterns we need to talk about some
Green Lanterns
um we need to get into them let's
see there are loads of top build
characters that are less powered and
Spidey they look awful in comparison to
Godlike characters that's true but you
know
it's
um question Rob what is your opinion
about renew your vows on Spider Girl AKA
Mayday Parker AKA spider
girl I think renew your vow is a good
idea I think it was high time they went
back and just got rid of of one more day
one more day is like this big blotch on
the already blotchy history of
Spider-Man and even shinski was like
look guys like yes I wrote that story
but they made me do it
like that's pretty much what happened he
was like look they kind of made me write
this story I don't you know don't shoot
the messenger was basically like what he
was saying to all the Spider-Man fans um
and so as a result you know it was um it
was just this terrible catastrophe it's
high time it went away so uh egg
scrambled are over
easy I like mine over medium actually
but uh let's see Marvel announced a
Great Lakes Avengers movie
with uh okay I that that question just
went away oh um what would be your
reaction I wouldn't take it seriously I
think it was a prank nobody's going to
take great legs Avengers seriously even
comic book fans would be like that's
ridiculous I'm never going to go see
that movie
so
ew one more day is that a gun in your
hand uh it is a gun that shoots vapor
into my mouth so that I can get my AIX
of nicotine so I guess it is kind of in
a way but not really this is actually Mr
Good Vape is the stuff that I'm using
right now so that's
nice
um let's see what's the deal with Agent
Venom does the Venom symbiot need Flash
in a way is it changing because of flash
actually if you guys want to see a
really good video on the Venom symbiot
um which I think will include Agent
Venom uh check out Benny's Channel I
think he's doing all the Venoms if he
hasn't
already uh what did Nick Fury thou say
uh we talked about that during the
weekly pool
podcast um I actually Dropped a Bomb at
the end of that episode of the podcast
which a lot of people were just like no
you can't just say that and then just
not say what like you can't just throw
that out
there um
I've read a little bit of ram the space
night um I
have I don't know it's I'm not a huge
fan about ROM the space n uh Iron Fist
or Shan Chi who would
win Danny Rand or shangi um it's like
Bruce Lee versus Chuck Norris I'm not
really sure um I don't think they've
ever actually fought in Marvel Comics
they may have but they're both
prodigious masters of martial arts but
Iron Fist has uh the Iron Fist
so he probably end up
winning um Deadpool can't die because of
Thanos right that's the perception and
as far as I know that still holds true
but it could be that he may very well
come back to life or may very well be
killed off I'm not 100% sure I haven't
followed Deadpool for quite some
time uh let's see who's the best Avenger
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
definitely Iron Man like he's a great
he's he's I think he's the glue that
holds everything together like makes the
movies fun to watch but the other
characters are really good too like
Steve Rogers is really solid um Thor is
really solid they're great additions to
the show or to the movie but I think
that Iron Man is really the one that
holds the uh holds the whole thing
together he makes it pretty pretty
awesome um I'm Comics explained explain
it
uh your Comics explain not Comics go
check out that guy that's a that's a
funny comment um who is The Grandmaster
I saw him in Planet Hulk and
DC um all right there's a grandmas in
Marvel Comics but I don't know who The
Grandmaster in DC would
be
[Laughter]
uh let's see oh God so many
questions so many questions coming in
now all right um we need to go we need
to find some some DC questions because a
lot of people like people have been
asking DC questions I feel like we've
been sticking to Marvel
um let's
see okay what do you think is happening
to Batman that is making a way for the
all new Batman what do you think is
happening I want to make sure I'm
reading it
right that is making way for the all new
Batman um I'm not really sure I think
that Batman in terms
of H
H it's it's it's difficult to
say you kind of have to look around at
what DC's doing overall especially like
with the Batman continuity to really I
think understand this one of the things
they're launching is I like we are Robin
like there's going to be a whole host of
teenage superheroes based on the
character Robin with uh with
Batman Batman death of the family the
bat family sort of ens shambles at this
point God uh bat ingame still isn't
finished yet uh I'm sorry Batman Eternal
still not finished yet Batman ingame
follows Eternal it's weird they're doing
it all out of
continuity honestly they're gonna I mean
they're going to keep Bruce Wayne as
Batman I don't see them getting rid of
him especially with the new 52
continuity where he is Batman but the
other thing to keep in mind too is that
what they're basically saying is they're
saying that everything that's happened
over the course of Batman's continuity
between the time when he first became
Batman when Bruce way first became
Batman and what we saw with Batman issue
number one that it's all been 5 years
years since all that's happened and so
as a
result this is basically everything
picking up like everything this this is
for those of you guys who are are new to
DC Comics for those of you guys who are
wanting to get into the new 52 what DC
did is they came back and they said okay
all the characters have zero years like
Wonder Woman uh Superman Green Lantern
how Jordan well not really how Jordan um
The Flash and so on and so forth all
these characters have zero years from
the time they first became the
superheroes until the time that they
actually had issue number one of their
respective Comics it was only a 5-year
window and so with Batman's continuity
only 5 years had passed between the time
that he had did Grayson is Robin and
then Jason Todd and then Jason Todd died
and then Tim Drake and then Dick Grayson
became Nightwing and so on and so forth
I think that they may end up going back
and looking at the idea of Nightfall I
think they may be going back and looking
at that the idea of final crisis I guess
it is um whichever one where he had uh
been lost in time and they might be
toying with the idea of killing off
Batman or having Batman go away it could
be and this would be one half hell of a
um one hell of a switch if the Joker
successfully killed Batman like imagine
that if the Joker actually killed Bruce
Wayne and Bruce Wayne was gone forever
and then they brought somebody else back
that that would be a that'd be huge
because they killed off Superman in The
Death of Superman um that would be nuts
if they killed off Batman entirely I
mean he was just gone forever that would
be or they killed off Bruce Wayne
rathera that would be something else I
don't know though I mean it'd be it'd be
interesting to sort of see what happens
but uh Batman Incorporated as well yeah
that's true see that that's that's one
of the funny things that I've learned is
is with this YouTube thing like whenever
I upload a video like I uploaded the
video about Tim Drake and people were
like um you missed the uh you missed it
it's actually infinite or final crisis
instead Infinite Crisis whatever it was
and that's that's a funny thing like
people love getting in and and being
like hey like you said this wrong like
people love correcting me which I don't
mind it because I I think at this point
on my channel I think that the that
people out there want to demonstrate
they know more than I do which is
probably true like I know know a lot
about Marvel I know a good amount about
DC now that I'm reading it more um but
there are people out there that'll blow
me out of the water so that's that's one
of the big uh one of the big big
differences
um it says Shane DC and Morrison copped
out at the end of final
crisis um if Bishop were to fight Bishop
were to fight Sebastian Shaw with equal
energy gained would it be an infinite
Loop of fire it would be like it would
go on forever well no it wouldn't be an
infinite Loop of fire because remember
the powers that Sebastian Shaw had in
X-Men Days of Future Past were actually
Bishop's powers like Bishop has the
ability to absorb energy and then to
keep that energy or to shoot it back out
at somebody well the problem is that is
think of it like this when it comes to
Bishop and his powers it's like a cup if
the cup continuously has water poured
into it it'll eventually overflow if the
cup overflows and Bishops Bishop will
die
um if
Bishop Bishop is a pain in the ass
character Bishop can store his powers
but his powers power is also passive
meaning that it happens without him
actually having to act on it so let's
let's let's say this for example a
better idea would
be if Bishop if they were going against
the foe whereby somebody could Channel
energy through Bishop you could have a
character like like Cyclops who could
shoot his optic beams at Bishop and then
Bishop could continually fire those fire
that energy in its own way back at
something else it would be cyclop
shooting Bishop Bishop shooting
something else that's how Bishop's power
Works he's basically like a living
battery for various forms of energy and
as far as I know he can absorb any kind
of energy there's no limit to the type
of energy he can absorb but if he's shot
with too much energy at one time and he
doesn't let it all off fast enough then
he'll die and that's what we saw in the
uh the Days of Future Past film I'm
sorry Sebastian Shaw an X-Men first
Class not days of future pass but that's
what we saw in the days of future P film
was that the Sentinels overwhelmed him
with too much power he couldn't let it
all out and as a result it uh ended up
causing him to explode so
um has tons of minority characters
they're called mutants well they used to
and then they killed them all off and
they took all their powers away so uh is
a battery short himm and he's a goner
yeah pretty much that's exactly what it
is
um what's your favorite Batman actor
um probably Christian Bale I think that
most people look at that version of
Batman and say it's the best
um now that's the best version of Batman
given the actors who have played Batman
are there characters out there who could
play Batman better than Christian Bale
yeah definitely there are definitely
actors out there that could play a much
better Batman than Christian Bale I'm
really interested to see how Ben Affleck
does I really can't wait to see what Ben
affle does in terms of his role as
Batman whether he'll be as good as
anybody else whether he'll be uh better
than the other actors we've seen is
really kind of up in the air um I think
that George Clooney playing the
billionaire aspect of Bruce Wayne was
really good I think his Batman was
terrible but the writing was was the
problem not so much Bruce not so much
George Clooney as an actor Val Kilmer
was just like me he was just kind of you
know it was emotionless acting on his
part um there were some characters that
were amazing and there were some
characters that were garbage in the end
it really just kind of depends
but
uh how do I feel about Dr Doom being
roomal we'll talk about that when we
make our video uh let's see have I read
Crossed no I haven't I actually haven't
um question what is your opinion of Tim
Drake's history getting screwed over in
New 52 Teen Titan sucks and question why
can't Batman Beyond AKA Terry mcginness
be Batman's successor um because Terry
mcginness being Batman's
successor uh well crap all these
questions are coming in I got to scroll
back up
um I mean as far as I know he's Batman's
successor from from the future like he
he was created in the TV show and
brought into the comics he was like
Harley Quinn um in terms of Tim Drake he
is I don't I don't think it's continu
got screwed over that bad I mean I guess
if you were a big Tim Drake fan before
the new52 but in the new52 run I mean he
they basically condensed it down in
secret Origins and Teen Titans issue
number zero um I don't think he's that
bad in new52 I mean he's still
relatively interesting I don't think
he's as relevant as he was pre- New 52
but that's because you already had d and
Wayne at that point and so the
significance of Tim Drake went away um
him playing Red Robin was a great way to
keep his character going but at the end
of the day Red Robin was no standin for
Jason Todd as red hood or even Dick
Grayson as Nightwing um that that was
one of the things that I thought about
talking about in that video but usually
whenever I make my video I just try to
bring the facts I try not to bring like
a biased opinion and so I try to simply
just say like here's how fans reacted to
this character here's what fans thought
about this character here's what they
did and so on and so forth I try to try
TR not to keep things biased because I
think it's a very slippery slope when
you uh when you walk walk down that path
but
ah removeal la being doomed was a new
Avengers issue number
31 does Batman smoke not to my
knowledge um uh favorite Superman actor
Nicholas Cage uh Rob do you think Marvel
may find a way to incorporate the
Scrolls in the MCU as far as no they
don't have oh no yeah we have the rest
of the Scrolls I think I don't know if
we have the rest of the Scrolls I don't
think they will um I think that no I
don't think they
will
uh do you know how fast you were
scrolling I don't know I don't know what
you mean
um Red Hood Solo movie could it happen I
I wish it would happened I would love to
see a Jason Todd as red hood film like I
would love to see that
um let's see I I know the Injustice
video game is part of the DC Comics
Multiverse do you think Justice League
Unlimited Animated Universe is part of
it as well um I'm not really sure I
don't think they've come out and said
that but if it is considered to be part
of the uh DC Multiverse then we'll see
that with convergence we'll see that as
one of the convergence stories um I
don't think it is uh I think that it's
really more just the animated thing that
it's kind of kept out there and just hey
look guys like this is just a separate
thing but it'd be cool to see the
Justice Justice League Unlimited team
joining the lineup of convergence and
actually seeing that alternate reality I
think it'd be pretty cool but um I'm not
really sure
uh let's see what's my favorite Lantern
core uh the Red
Lanterns which we need to do all the
different Lantern cores even if even if
just for the sake of it like I think
it'd be fun to do videos about the
Lantern core so um the Red Lantern like
I was I went with a friend of mine and
his son to uh to Comic Con yesterday and
uh here in Lexington and me and his son
were talking about um the all the the
lantern cores and he was saying his
favorite was the Lantern core too and I
think I think that'd be cool like to go
through and just like go over all the
lantern cores let me know if you guys
would be interested in seeing that kind
of thing if you guys would be interested
in me going over the Lantern
core let's
see what other Avengers haven't we seen
yet do you want to be in the infinity
War film
um let's see The Avengers lineup that we
have now is going to be the Avengers
lineup going into Infinity War but if I
had to see them add a couple people to
that lineup um definitely Jessica Jones
definitely Daredevil uh Luke Cage would
have to be a must because he has
indestructible skin
um let's see maybe clo and Dagger would
be kind of a cool addition um I wouldn't
mind seeing some Captain Britain
representation just because I think he
has a very long history and uh I think
he's pretty important but um let's see
yeah Benny already did the whole thing
on all the lantern cores so I I don't
know um let's
see already overflows us with Lantern
stuff
uh let's
see is that an iTaste MVP no but I do
have an MVP this is a uh
ipv2 uh Franklin Richards versus
Superman uh Franklin Richards he would
just F Superman out of existence let's
see
uh white lanterns are the strongest the
lanterns of life um what is your
favorite DCU animated movie it's
actually funny that you asked that
because I went on this kick where I was
watching the DCU animated films um I
thought Batman whichever one it was it
had Carrie Kelly where Batman was old I
thought that was a good one um I think
that was Batman zeroy year no it wasn't
Batman zero year that was
Batman uh I don't remember what which
one which Batman one that was but I I
thought it was pretty cool um let's see
the one where the Joker comes back
basically
uh I thought um oh God what was
it I've seen a few of
them maybe that was Batman Brave and the
Bold I don't remember but um in any
event no I've I've I think that God I'm
trying to remember all the different
ones that I saw I saw the ones where
they had like a combination of films in
like mini movies um where you had like
uh let's see Black Adam versus
Shazam
um God that my mind completely drew a
blank I guess are the ones that I do
remember I liked um Black Adam versus
Shazam the most but nonetheless uh let's
see oh dark KN returns there we go thank
you guys thank you guys I knew I knew
you DC fans would be like oh my God Rob
it's dark night Returns come on like get
it together
man everybody's chiming
in oh man everybody like it's dark night
returns man it's dark night returns my
[Laughter]
God God there's so many people who are
saying Dark Knight Returns there's
hundreds of responses saying Dark Knight
Returns
um let's see so all right so here's my
here's my question for you
guys what's your favorite storyline from
DC Comics that's what I want to know
like what's your favorite
thing
uh if you could have three superpowers
what will they be oh God that's a good
question well they couldn't be overt
superpowers because I wouldn't want
anybody to know that I had them um I
also wouldn't want to make my life a
burden so I would say my first
superpower would be telepathy with
perfect control that way I could do
pretty much anything I wanted to I could
give my like move a glass towards me or
I could do any number of things
um the second one I wouldn't want
telepathy because telepathy would just
be a hassle um or no okay let's say
telepathy with perfect uh perfect
control so I could hear only what I
wanted to hear from people like I could
well I guess I could listen to their
minds but I could immediately tune them
out if they started saying something I
didn't like um and I guess the third one
would be the ability to manipulate um I
guess luck in my favor so that I could
like win the lottery and stuff like that
that'd be
cool um see Batman zero year death of
the family Batman year One The Killing
Joke Court of
owls uh Hush Hush is a good one
um let's see when Wally West has his
kids uh The Killing Joke see I wouldn't
want a healing Factor because I wouldn't
want to live forever um Emerald
Twilight Lobo paramilitary
Christmas crisis on infinite
Earths
uh Nightfall kingdom comes you guys have
some pretty cool uh pretty cool
favorites in the uh in the DC continuity
death in the
family so many things so okay so of the
Marvel stories then which ones are your
favorite stories from Marvel Comics
which we may have asked that before but
I don't remember what the answer is for
so give me the rundown of your favorite
stories of Marvel Comics uh could you
count Thor being able to move his hammer
with a simple hand command a telepathy
power Oh you mean like when
he when his when he thinks like when he
moves his hand just by virtue of just
being like a person and being able to
move his hand that because his mind is
doing that that is that is I guess I
don't know I don't I don't understand
what you mean I'm a little confused by
your
question um let's
see the one where the superhero from DC
uh uh all right should Terry Cruz play
John Stewart in the upcoming DCU movies
no I think that um that Idis Elba would
be a great John Stewart for the DC films
I think he' probably be be the best one
um the centry origin oh God Cent's
origin is so good it's hands down one of
the best stories
ever um kingdom comes amazing but it is
an elor so it's hard to
count Civil War so many responses for
Civil War I knew people were probably
they're going to be a lot of fans for
civil war Infinity Wars uh Siege the
Children's
Crusade death of the Stacy spiderverse
Civil War Infinity gaun that's a good
one death of wolverin astonishing X-Men
Jos weeden's entire
run what do I think of the fan films of
Harley Quinn and Dick Grayson um I
actually haven't seen those um send me a
message on Twitter with the links to
those so I can check those out um
Kingdom Come zero zero tolerance was a
good one that was the whole thing with
oh God man you're going old school that
was a whole thing with um Bastion I
think God that was an old
one I
mean God that was an old one if I
remember correctly that's the one where
Bastion who was the the nrod you want to
talk about a cool character in Marvel
Comics Nimrod was the shiznit like he
was awesome back in the day I miss
Nimrod he was a great character I always
wanted to do a video about Nimrod we may
do a video about him one day he was a
great character who do I think lady Thor
is I think lady Thor is uh Jane Foster
what's going on Lian I think that's how
you pronounce it um I think I'm the only
one here that loved fear
itself I wasn't a big fan of the fan of
fear um four of Kings was a really
really good one one uh Jonathan
Hickman's Future Foundation hey Rob what
do you think of the new Batman Beyond
that's coming out I think oops let's
scroll up a little bit I think it's
going to be great what do you think
about the writers and the artists are on
it if so please let me know I don't know
a whole lot about the writers and the
artists who are doing it I know they're
changing things up but I'm interested to
see what they're going to do with Batman
Beyond postcon convergence like I'm
really looking forward to see what the
characters what they're going to do with
Terry
mcginness
um do I think the MCU will include the
iron
spider uh yeah definitely I think it'll
include the iron spider outfit I mean it
would have to I mean it'd be a great way
to differentiate between Spider-Man and
the Sony universe and Spider-Man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe uh no you
cannot have you cannot have the
Incredible Hulk
picture let's
see what's your opinion of Deadpool's
secret secret Wars I'm going to read it
and we'll do a video about it
uh Jane Foster is worthy yep we're going
to talk about that in our video today
uh let's
see never gonna stop backing terine for
lady Thor until I am proven
wrong
uh Kyle rer or John Stewart for a movie
John Stewart definitely he needs his own
movie um do you have more questions for
us I like asking you guys questions I I
think I think see here's here's the
issue that I have with a lot of q&as a
lot of q&as that exists out there it's
just like like fans asking their
favorite YouTubers questions the
YouTubers never ask questions in return
so let's let's think of let's think have
some more questions for you guys because
I like asking you guys questions I like
asking you guys because I know you guys
are like me like as comic book fans you
guys love talking like explaining comic
books to people I know I know you guys
love that like oh my God someone who
doesn't know anything about this
character let's explain it to
them I know you guys are all about that
kind of thing um
so
okay
um this was addressing the latest issue
of Thor you are 100% right she she yes
Jane Foster does have cancer
um we're going to address that in our
video because just because you guys are
saying that Jane Foster in the earth 616
Universe has cancer does it mean that
Jane Foster still can't be Thor so
uh I am worth the power of
Thor
um let's see okay yeah yeah so questions
for you guys um we love we do love it
and we love
you okay for those of you guys who are
keeping track um what's going on Brent
for those of you guys who are keeping
track we're going to do Daman Damen
Wayne explain oh my God I got to I got
to ask this damn question for those of
you guys who are keeping track of what's
been revealed about rabom all's identity
and for those of you guys who haven't
been keeping track you're going to have
it spoiled for you what do you guys
think about rabu malal being Dr Doom
about that
reveal let me let me know what you guys
think about that do I play Hero clicks
actually a friend of mine Ross one of a
really good friend that I've known for
about 10 years plays hero clicks and
he's been dying to get me to play and I
keep telling him when you guys get
together and you guys to play Hero
clicks let me know and he's like well we
kind of get together whenever we get a
chance
so uh bring the intro back nope the
intro is not coming back um Justice
League Tower of Babel that was a good
one I did this to
you they should make a movie about that
like they should have Liam niss as uh as
Ral ghoul and they should make a movie
about Tower of Babel uh the Joker new
for to explained we'll get into that we
we'll get into the Joker uh we need to
do a video explaining the Joker and then
we're going to get into the Joker um
with regards to the new 52 um going into
uh the
uh Batman endgame and things like that
see here's the problem Batman Eternal is
not finished and Batman Eternal is going
to continue on and then it's going to
take a break during convergence and then
it's going to come back next year I
think and so like Batman endgame is the
end of all that so basically they gave
us the ending before the story was
completed and so it's going to be kind
of a hassle um so it's going to be
difficult to do but we'll definitely do
the Joker's New 52
story let's
see um
people were pretty psyched about
it is Dr Doom still important these days
yes Dr Doom is actually incredibly
important now he is probably one of the
most important characters probably the
most important character in the entire
Marvel Universe right now so
uh let's see what's your current pool
list um the uh the ongoing Batman
Eternal um New Avengers Avengers because
that's where uh Hickman's story for
leading up to sear Wars is going to
conclude in
um oh god um uh Star Wars uh Princess
Leia when that comes out um and Darth
Vader so that's my current current pool
list not the biggest pool list in the
world but I'm really picky about the uh
the comics that I do that I actually
like you know set up as a pool list for
me to constantly go into everything else
I have I usually just go to the store
prise around for a little bit buy it and
then leave
so um it wouldn't be secret Wars without
an OP Dr Doom that is 100%
true uh Rob how do you feel about ingame
saying Joker's Immortal we actually had
a big discussion about the immortality
of Joker in um in the the
podcast I think that what they're saying
here isn't necessarily so much that The
Joker Is Immortal but that the Joker is
the inherent representation of what evil
is that the Joker just can't be stopped
and that Batman has is the opposite that
that joker is Goliath and Batman is
David more or less um not a big fan of
that I was a big fan of the fact that
the Joker was just a man who had a bad
day day like I loved that element I mean
that was the theme of The Killing Joke
just one bad day and I think that's what
made him such a loved character was
because he was a guy who had one bad day
and as a result he lost his mind
entirely um I think that made him human
I think that made him someone who could
be defeated but the the idea to me was
not the defeat of the Joker I didn't
care anything about the Joker being
defeated it was totally irrelevant to me
what loved what I love so much about the
story was just the back and forth
between the two was the fact that no
matter what happened no matter what
Batman did no matter what lengths he
went to there was nothing he could do to
fix the Joker the penguin went to a
relatively uh I guess not as criminal
life as everybody else for a little
while and of course he had that lounge
or whatever it was then he went back to
being a criminal again Twoface was
reformed for a time I mean you had
various criminals from Batman's Rogues
Gallery who had tried to redeem
themselves but the Joker never did that
the Joker was just so far gone from
sanity there was nothing you could do to
fix it and one of the coolest things was
actually stated
in oh my God what was it I can't
remember what story it was oh it was
like
Batman Batman number three or number
four from way back in the 19 back back
in the Golden Age where he said the
Joker's insane schemes don't make sense
to anybody but himself and they actually
use the same phrase in Batman the
Animated Series but that right there I
think symbolizes the Joker The Joker
only the Joker understands why he does
what he does and even then the Joker
doesn't understand it he doesn't know it
and so this is why we need to do a video
about the Joker guys so we can get into
how crazy The Joker Is like it's it's
such a cool concept The Joker Is I think
a lot of people will debate this a lot
of people will argue about this for from
now until the end of time but I think
that the Joker is a
representation of what it means to just
give in that dark side of yourself
because I think everybody has that I
think everybody has that side of
themselves with sometimes they just want
to let go they just want to let go of it
all they just want to say the hell with
it they just want to say they don't care
about rules they don't care about laws
or any of that stuff and they just want
to go out and they just want to do their
own thing the Joker is our ability to
read about a character who can just give
in to his Insanity it's our Escape as
readers it's our ability to read about a
guy who just doesn't care it's our
ability to read about a guy who can just
do whatever he wants when he wants and
all he's ever going to get is some
interm period in um in uh Arkham Asylum
and then eventually escape and go about
doing it again so yeah we're definitely
going to do a video about the Joker uh
let's
see I heard the rocket playing Black
Adam how do you feel about that uh I
mean I'm pretty excited about oh my God
a wrestling question all right favorite
WWE wrestler uh are we talking about now
or in the history of wrestling because
if we're talking about in the history of
wrestling
then oh my God if we're talking about in
the history of wrestling then I would
say my favorite character of all time
was Bill Goldberg like Bill Goldberg was
amazing he captivated
I mean he was UN he was completely
undefeated of course it was all stag but
he was completely undefeated um but if
we're talking about the current run of
wrestling that I have no idea
WrestleMania 30 I went to and that was
really the last time I kept up with
wrestling anymore
[Laughter]
so uh Comic character philosophy
explained where's your coffee my coffee
has been replaced with some water in a
Jimmy
cup WWE is fake but it's still pretty
badass um let's
see what do I think Dr Doom's plan with
the molecule man is that is what we
don't know um that's the big confusion a
lot of people
have supposedly well we'll get into this
in our video but I think he's basically
going to do his best to basically remake
reality and then put himself at the peak
of this new universe because remember
every single scheme that Dr Doom has
been in has always been to gain power
that's always what Dr Doom does what's
going on Michael Garcia that's always
the role of Dr Doom is to gain as much
power as they possibly can oh my God all
these wrestling comments Stone Cold
Steve Austin explained NWO forever oh
yeah NWO is the tits let me tell you
guys
something I don't know how many of you
guys are my age or how many of you guys
are are 30 or how many of you guys were
watching wrestling in the 1990s but let
me tell you guys something when they had
that episode episode of Monday Nitro I
think it was where Scott Hall and Kevin
Nash came out that was unbelievable
people were just like oh my God like it
blew people away and then when you had
bash of the beach 1996 and Hogan came
out and he was the third man for the
NWO I have never in my entire wrestling
watching career I guess ever seen an
instance where people where fans reacted
to something like that where they threw
trash crash into the ring where they
turned against Hogan and I remember
watching this interview uh not too long
after I think it was the Monday night
Wars actually the documentary where um
Hogan was talking about that and Eric
Bishoff were talking about that and
Hogan said that he called Eric Bishoff
and said we've got something like we've
got something amazing here and they took
it and ran with it and then Eric bishaw
[__] it all up so you know it's
whatever Doom is a boss Doom is always
pulling the strings um um I've never
read Gru I don't know what guu is
uh let's see question what is your
opinion of ultimate Dr Doom and the
Ultimate Marvel Universe ending this
year it's time for the Ultimate Universe
to come to an end I never liked the
Ultimate Universe Kevin Nash is
hype Mayweather versus
Pacquiao I don't really want to watch
some lightweight boxers if I'm going to
watch a boxing match I'm going to watch
a heavyweight world Title Boxing Match
which I missed that we don't really get
like like see boxing isn't like it used
to be like I think the last great boxing
match was of Andrew Holyfield and Mike
Tyson where he bit his ear off that was
the last great boxing
match um John Cena versus haggus show me
potato
salad I don't know if any of you guys
follow the potato salad subreddit but
over at reddit.com there's a subreddit
called potato salad that's dedicated to
John Cena and all they do is just like
like they're like hey guys like here's
here's here's an awesome picture of
potato salad and it's uh it'll just be
pictures of John
Cena it's hilarious they actually had
this uh video where um they I don't know
if you guys watched Family Guy but there
was the post-apocalypse one where they
came across those homeless guys and U
they were like all right like you take
three things on a picnic like which
things do you take and Lois or I think
the whole family agreed like potato
salad and so the homeless guy was like
show me potato salad and then like the
camera panned over and John Cena was
standing there and played his intro
music it was pretty awesome um all right
so do a video explaining why Batman
doesn't kill Joker that would go into
our Joker video that'd be part of that
part of that video um what do you think
of the Batman bunny suit I'm not gonna
talk about
that um let's see Thor versus Shazam
that would be a good one that would be
an interesting one I would love to see
that I think that'd be a cool video to
see or a cool uh a fight to see
um I think Shazam his he's more magic
oriented than Thor is um Thor just has
super strength and he has his hammer
which is Enchanted with magic but Thor
himself isn't necessarily magical so I
think itd be a good thing I think that
ultimately Thor would be able to defeat
uh Shazam entirely I think the real
question here would be could Shazam
wield Thor's hammer if he was worthy of
wielding Thor's hammer which between a
conflict in the two of them I doubt he
would be but if he was worthy of
wielding Thor's hammer then I would say
Shazam could take it if not then it'll
probably go in Thor's
favor uh what do I think of bat cow
Rob bat cow bat cow oh my God it was it
was funny me and again going back to
Comic Con yesterday uh me and a friend
of mine when I was talking to his son we
were talking about bat cow and and I
asked him I was like what is your love
for batow and he was like bow is awesome
he actually wanted me to do a video
about um all the uh the animal sidekicks
which I think bny did that actually now
that I think about it but um nonetheless
bat cow was funny to me it was funny
seeing like a cow run in front of a car
and like save the car and it was funny
seeing um Tim Drake I think it was like
we're not going to let this cow die like
we're going to save this cow and this
cow is going to be called back cow and
if I were Bruce Wayne I would have been
like no dude like like we're having Stak
tonight I don't know but I think beckow
was was a hilarious and a great way to
break the monotony of some of the um
some of the Batman
comics uh thoughts if stellos Kos was in
the N MCU I have no idea who that is
actually backout versus Punisher backout
definitely The Punisher wouldn't know
what to do he would just be like oh my
God like a cow and then by that time
backa would have just like ran him over
and then stomped on him and then he
would have killed him
so
um Shazam is probably worthy since he's
inocent as a kid yeah but innocence
doesn't immediately mean that you have
the ability to wield THS
Hammer uh let's see Hulk beats doomsday
uh
maybe let's see bat
steak
yep bat T-Bone bat
ribey uh let's
see uh do I watch Varan Comics yeah AIS
has awesome videos um for those of you
guys who don't know about AIS and I
don't know why you wouldn't but for
those of you you guys who don't know
about AIS um he is very in comics Aeris
is he he reached the number one spot in
um the top 10 list for um watch Mojo's
top 10 comic book YouTube channels and
uh he was doing this long before we were
so AIS is is pretty fantastic at what he
does so definitely check him out it's
just varying comics on
YouTube um let's see do I even like
Miles Morales oh yeah miles Miles
Morales is an incredible character I
like how gritty and realistic a story is
that's that's the thing I love about his
character um let's
see let's
uh what's that thing you smoke on every
podcast this is my ecigarette it helps
keep me sane all right guys um since I
have a video that I need to finish
working on and I need to have it
uploaded by the time uh hopefully around
6:30 or so I'm going to go ahead and
bring this one to an end and uh and yeah
so so I love talking with you guys uh
comics and coffee hopefully next week s
will be with us um I I invited him and
he was like well I just woke up so um he
I think he said he wanted to come on
next week so hopefully we'll see him
then but um but yeah we might I think
we'll keep this as like a 12:00 in the
afternoon kind of thing that way it'll
give me time to wake up and sort of get
it together and it'll give you guys on
the East Coast time to wake up and kind
of get it together and we can we can go
from there so with that being said um I
we'll catch you guys later peace oh by
the way whenever I do my videos and I'm
like I'm like we're g to bring this
video T an in and I will catch you guys
later peace like I actually do that like
I actually make the peace sign in my
videos so anyway I'll catch you guys
later peace